um all right let's try seven three to
call her from seven three to let me know
your name where you're calling from and
what's on your mind today
hey David it's Kyle from Philly again
great what's going on uh not too much
honestly I didn't think I'd get through
this time but I just had a thought in my
head I think we could bring Pat to this
conversation because it has to do with
veganism and organic food do you guys
believe that there's a classism to
eating like organic vegan vegetarian
diets is there a way we can make it more
affordable how do we fix this problem so
that we can eat healthier as a nation
absolutely I mean I think anybody you
it's much more rare to see you know
people who are paleo or fruitarians who
are living in poverty than our middle
class or higher because anytime you are
it's rare that there's any kind of
special diet that is consuming cheaper
calories of course the cheapest calories
being processed foods refined foods
foods that have corn in them in
different forms which is heavily
subsidized so anytime I mean there's
definitely a privileged element outside
of countries where you know in parts of
India vegetarianism is just the default
diet for example outside of those
situations though typically eating any
sort of non default diet is going to be
more likely not seen in people who are
poor I mean I don't know is so is the
question how to make it more affordable
yeah like like for example I saw that
there's a start-up that's called Brandis
I believe forget to startup where it's
not entirely just health food but
they're trying to sell you know organic
non-gmo kinds of food but it's
sustainable it makes sense for three
dollars I looked at the website and it
seemed like you know it's affordable the
portions weren't necessarily comparable
to other products that you would see in
a Whole Foods that I mean I
well I have never heard of that company
and I don't know how much food you get
for $3 I mean so I could not possibly
comment on that I think one of the
general movements it's not about a
particular startup that's gonna create a
paradigm shift on affordable healthy
food part of it is going to be local
production and we've seen this explored
through like when it comes to produce
vertical farming prototypes that have
been seen growing food in urban centers
so that food and cities doesn't have to
be trucked in from far away those are
some of the things I'm thinking of Pat
that are gonna make healthy food more
affordable right and from the vegans
perspective I think a lot of people have
this perception that a vegan diet is
more pricey because they may see mock
meats or like go to these posh e salad
places and everything costs like 1015
dollars but if you just boil it down to
just Whole Foods you're talking about
potatoes you talk about rice you talk
about core and those are some of the
cheapest things you can find out and
there's a reason why corn is cheap
absolutely yes little subsidized and
then when we send out aid packages to
foreign countries we send them just
vegetables and in starches for the most
part because that's cheaper and it
doesn't expire nearly as quickly as you
say meats would yeah sure
so I think those are some ideas but I
you know it's food startups are great
but I don't know that a food startup is
going to be what revolutionize is
healthy eating I mean we also have food
deserts remember huge parts of this
country where the closest place to get
fresh produce is pretty far away and
that's not going to make it any cheaper
if you now have to drive on top of
paying more for produce which is more
expensive on a per calorie basis so
those what do you have any ideas Kyle I
think definitely buying local is the
best way that we can make food cheaper
and I think we need to as a country just
accept that maybe if we eat locally and
try not to import food from further away
first-level decrease our environmental
damage but maybe that'll start lowering
prices because you know Whole Foods has
been responsible for kind of raising
prices at not just their own stores but
that affects the market for farmers
market you know used to be more
affordable to buy organic produce at a
local farmers market around here now
it's comparable to Whole Foods prices
because they kind of set the mood
oh this is how much it cost to buy
tomatoes or yeah here those prices are
affected by the Amazon buyout of Whole
Foods as well they claim they're gonna
lower prices okay Kyle thanks very much
appreciate the phone call very important
issue cost of food healthy diets all
very important